correct me if I'm wrong but you don't
have an agent or a manager and they are
actually quite difficult to get hold of
when people want to get you in a movie
well I don't have an agent I don't have
a manager and I don't have a publicist I
don't even have a I have a physical
therapist probably but I don't I don't
have all those things you know so how
did I George Clooney managed to write
you into this maybe there well he called
someone that I know that goes to how do
I call the mutual friend and that friend
got to me and did all the legwork would
you would you go about it in that way
well I've done it the other way and it
just takes too much of my time I'm not
very organized person so I feel like if
I can eliminate a lot of these
distractions and people that there's
always someone tugging on your trousers
you know do this and there was just too
much that all became too much and I just
thought I could try to do it on my own
and see what happened and it's been
great I don't have all that distraction
the phone doesn't ring all day long I
don't you know I get to do some things I
want
and the people that really want to
finally find me so you please then that
you got involved in this project
yeah it's it's great this is a nice
bunch I mean you see it's a nice bunch
of guys you know John Goodman and Matt
Damon and Taliban and who's John these
are then it's been a great bunch of
people but especially George George's
really really takes care of everyone
George is a very very professional
director he knows exactly what he wants
to do we come to the work and we do our
job and we laugh and we stop and laugh
all day long all through the day we stop
and laugh and that's why we've been on
this sort of pumping around the
continent doing this and this is work
this isn't easy - it's all you do
there's no time for fun or shopping or
clubs or anything we're just doing this
only really because George took such
great care of us on the job it's never
been like that before
you were starring in Ghostbusters when
George Clooney was still you know
appearing uncredited in in various
movies back in there back in the
eighties so how does it feel you know a
number of years later then taking
direction from George clearly is it
difficult do you sometimes have a
conflicts of opinions no I don't have
any conflict of opinions with them I
mean I might have an idea or two but
George is someone this works really hard
and what he does he understands what it
means to really work he understands that
you do the best work when you relaxed
when you're comfortable you do the best
work when you take care of people that's
sort of the Gypsy way on the movies you
take care of everyone on the set
whatever it is George is a good man I
wish I'd met George sooner